Ого, тут двіжуха!
Я в Херсоні живу з 1983-го року.
Навчався в Києві,
але повернувся до Херсона.
Я люблю Херсон, мені тут комфортно.
Мені подобається ритм життя,
мені подобаються тут люди.
Ми створили таке місце тяжіння,
точку концентрації,
де почали збиратися цікаві,
креативні, вільні люди,
за якими майбутнє.
Все найкраще, що відбувається в місті,
відбувається на локації Urban CAD.
Я зрозумів, що бізнес заради бізнесу —
це вже нецікаво і невчасно.
Потрібно створювати проєкти,
які будуть і корисні суспільству,
і годуватимуть мою сім'ю.
Тоді я вже дізнався про соціальне
підприємництво, почав ним займатися,
багато їздили,
переймали досвід інших міст
і ми хотіли створити
свій навчальний продукт,
який би дозволив херсонцям
не витрачати багато часу
на подорож до Львова,
Києва чи інших розвинутих міст.
І щоб рівень спікерів, тренерів був
такий самий, як у великих містах,
але щоб це було більш
доступно і фінансово, і по часу.
Ми хотіли під новий формат школи
знайти якусь нову локацію.
Херсон був промисловою
столицею півдня України.
В нас було дуже багато
великих підприємств,
але сьогодні змінилась
економіка, змінилось усе,
є багато просторів,
які в центрі міста,
але вони на сьогодні
не задіяні у виробництві.
Тоді ми дізналися про нове для нас поняття —
ревіталізація промислових просторів —
вдихання нового життя
в старі промислові будівлі.
Ми почали шукати, які в нас є «заброшки»,
недобудови або заводи і фабрики.
І коли подивилися на ці будівлі,
то зрозуміли, що це воно, це наше.
Це був колишній вентиляційний цех,
де стояли величезні турбіни,
які ганяли повітря по всьому заводу.
У нас виникла ідея створити
центр креативних індустрій,
арт-платформу «Турбіна».
Найголовніше, чого ми навчилися, —
це бачити в усіх проблемах можливості.
Біля турбіни був захаращений дворик,
де були фруктові дерева,
занедбані лавочки,
і ми вирішили:
«О, так може тут створити якийсь сад?
А ми ж у місті, сад у місті — це ж круто!
Місто, урбан, о — буде Urban CAD».
І ми вирішили створити open space простір,
який став би концентрацією
всього креативного в місті.
2,5 місяці ми працювали тут своїми
родинами, своїми руками, мізками.
Хто що вмів: варити, носити, фарбувати,
хтось — не заважати, хтось — надихати.
І так командою ми створили Urban CAD.
Яке було завдання?
Ми об'єднали херсонських
митців, художників
і кожному надали можливість
залишити свій внесок
у першому креативному просторі міста.
Це мій найулюбленіший мурал.
Його намалювала 16-річна дівчинка.
Для мене це найкрутіша штука.
Тут відбуваються усі
найактуальніші події міста.
Культурні, благодійні, музичні,
театральні заходи — будь-які.
Найбільший екран міста
також у Urban CADу — 130 квадратних метрів.
Тут ми транслюємо кліпи,
концерти, кінопокази,
а вчора дивились, як
Україна «зробила» Швейцарію – 2:1.
І завжди, коли ми тут
уболіваємо за Україну, вона виграє.
Якщо перший сезон Urban CAD
сприймали як щось незрозуміле,
коли ми вже відпрацювали другий сезон,
про нас говорили: «Ну, щось у цьому є».
Третій сезон:
«Як ми жили до того раніше?»
Четвертий сезон:
до нас уже приїхав GOGOLFEST.
Це зовсім прорив!
Привіт!
Зараз ми йдемо до мабутньої «Турбіни».
Завдяки GOGOLFESTу вона трохи оживає.
Там ще трошки трешовенько,
але вона оживає.
Для людей найголовніше —
не супергламурні умови.
Для них важливі свобода,
можливість самовиражатися,
можливість спілкуватися
з однодумцями і знаходити їх тут.
Мені здається, GOGOLFEST — це назавжди,
це поштовх для розвитку
і нашого проєкту, і міста.
Тут уже є інсталяції, малюнки, мурали,
тут буде перформативна програма,
тут буде візуальна програма.
[російською] Засвічуся в кадрі,
як прибиральниця на GOGOLFEST.
[російською] Я, взагалі-то, художниця.
В мене ідей не було, тому я вже
котрий день допомагаю художникам.
В мене дочка завтра
бере участь у перформансі.
Наш потенціал — це люди.
Ми все життя шукаємо своїх людей.
Завдяки таким проєктам ми їх знаходимо.
Команда Urban CADа —
це не люди, а якісь надлюди.
Для нас вихідні — це вже мрія,
яку треба візуалізувати,
і дуже багато робити, аби вони сталися.
У нас є такий прикол: «Коли у нас там
вихідні? — Ось, ось скоро, у листопаді».
Це команда фанатів, ідейних людей,
і оскільки це соціальне підприємництво,
то комерційна частина нашого
Urban CADу дозволяє проводити
дуже багато благодійних, культурних,
дитячих заходів безкоштовно.
Також ми даємо можливість нашим
початківцям- творцям, митцям, музикантам
виходити на інший рівень,
на іншу аудиторію,
відкривати себе, як мінімум, Херсону.
Найголовніша мотивація —
це бути причетними до змін у місті
і до всього, що відбувається в Urban CADу.
Ми отримали великий кредит довіри,
що люди до нас приходять і просто
нам допомагають — всі вмикаються.
У нас був рекорд —
150 волонтерів з міста приїхали
допомагати нам запустити новий сезон.
Містяни полюбили Urban CAD і відчувають,
що ми любимо місто, любимо херсонців.
Ми впевнені, що для Херсона креативні
індустрії мають стати центром перезапуску
і такою нішою, яка може витягнути
наше місто на новий рівень.
Наша мета — щоб ми залишалися в Херсоні
і пишалися тим, що ми херсонці,
бо сьогодні є проблема,
що 70% випускників шкіл лишають нашу область.
Вони їдуть до Києва, Львова, Одеси
і далі — до Словаччини, та і всієї Європи.
І ми втрачаємо наш потенціал.
Перше, що нам потрібно зробити, — це
якісь такі великі проєкти, які дадуть надію.
Хотілося б, щоб щомісяця
в Херсоні був якийсь масштабний захід —
театральний, джазовий, класичної музики,
щоб в нас кожного місяця
були круті інтелігентні туристи,
щоб до нас приїжджали
і відкривали для себе
Херсон, нашу природу,
наших людей з усього світу.
Коли ми були в Києві,
зустрічалися з Владом Троїцьким,
були на його лекції в ДАХу,
там були хлопці з Херсона, які поїхали
років п'ять тому, і вони сказали:
«А, ви з Херсона?
Ви команда Urban CAD?
Якби я знав, що ви ось-ось
відкриєтеся, я би з Херсона не поїхав».
І це мотивує.
Для мене великий страх — прожити життя
так, що нічого не залишиться після мене.
І обрана тема GOGOLFESTа —
«dream» — невипадкова.
Частина херсонців — в тій частині «dream»,
яка «сон», — вони сплять,
а є невеличка частина
активних людей, які «dream» — «мрія».
Мені здається, що я з тими, що мріють,
але не тільки мріють, але й щось роблять,
щоб ця мрія розбудила тих, що сплять,
і залучала їх до наших мрій.
І щоб вони відчували,
що поряд з цими крейзі хлопцями
і дівчатами нам усе вдасться.
Це про наше сприйняття міста
і сприйняття себе у цьому місті.
Якщо ми почнемо думати,
що ми тут назавжди,
що ми тут сьогодні, завтра
і тут будуть наші діти жити,
то почнемо щось створювати по-іншому.
Херсон побачив, Херсон прокидається.
І оцей комплекс провінційності і
меншовартості кудись починає ховатися.
І це найцінніше, що відбувається.